大家好，歡迎大家，這是
主動推理嘉賓流 28.1，現在是
2022 年 10 月 14 日。
今天我們將聽取和
討論 Giovanni Rolla 的重新認識理性，
所以 Giovanni
非常感謝大家的加入，非常
期待這次演講和
討論 謝謝，
謝謝，那麼很高興在
幾個月前收到你的邀請
，我很高興
能有機會在這裡討論我的
工作，
嗯，我會放棄你的要求，
我們的建議，我正在介紹
這個 幾年前我寫的論文
，嗯，當我們在後台談論時，
我有我已經改變了幾次主意
，自從我發表那篇論文以來，我將在演講中明確這一點
，但我
很高興 儘管如此，還是有機會
在這裡展示這個視頻並
與世界分享，所以我很
高興，
所以我們將討論
重新認識理性，這就是
這就是
行程 我正在考慮
向您介紹，所以首先我將
談論理性和
無內容的認知，然後我將介紹
我的觀點，我稱之為完全
不活躍的理性和安全詞，
關於代理和熟練的互動
以及推理和理性，它們
與一對夫婦關係密切 反對意見的
第一個是
我在場的任何東西都是真正的
自由主義者，在某種程度上過於自由它
包含了太多
，我認為
您最感興趣的第二個反對意見是
它是否與效果兼容
我們的預測編碼中的預測
過程當然是在設施中，它
靠近中央的兩輛汽車
以產生積極影響，
所以
這是
抱歉，我對此事的最初想法
是傳統上非常
正統 對理性有看法
嗯，據我所知，
這實際上是一個假設，
理性必須在他們
的推理中 當且僅當存在支持 Bure 的推理時，我相信 B 在
動作 a 中是理性的
根據這部傳統
電影，如此相信和理性行事的啟發式方法
需要滿足某些形式標準
，正如我所說，在我看來，這在
很大程度上是關於
在推理方面定義理性意味著什麼的假設，
所以如果理性需要推理
和 如果推理涉及
根據某些正式基準對信念進行評估，
那麼理性意味著
認知內容，
其中我認為內容具有最低限度
的準確性條件
能夠是
對或錯，或者在更
重要的概念中是真還是假，
所以 這裡的想法是理性
必然涉及內容它涉及
信念 推理和比較或
抱歉現在更新
一個軟件更新我很抱歉
我的窗口中有一個彈出窗口，所以
嗯
，我認為這是
關於理性的標準觀點
，
如果是這樣的話，理性必然
涉及 內容它非常
適合古典認知主義或
一般認知主義，
這是一種觀點，即組合
至少對於某些
認知主義者來說必然涉及表象內容，當然它也可能
涉及概念內容，但
至少具有表象內容
準確性條件，
但這種經典觀點不太好，
它不能很好地適應
完全不活躍和具
身的認知，我在這裡，呃，不是專門考慮
古德溫·緬因在最近的書中的激進和激進主義，但我
認為它也挑戰了其他
沒有被呈現為激進和
積極的觀點，但當然它們與激進和積極的觀點共享一些
核心租戶 sm
我們可以稱它們為 uh 從根本上體現
的認知觀點，例如
um 與 Ezekiel
Powell 或 Berman
感官模型生活所提出的觀點，你也有
Gallagher 在他
2017 年的書中的各種不作為，還有我的意思
是 Tony kimero 在他的觀點 2009 年出版的關於
生態心理學和動力
系統的書，它們都有共同的租戶
，在這裡我知道這是非常
有爭議的，但我將這些
觀點視為從根本上體現的
認知觀點，但我特別
關注激進和積極的
烹飪觀點
他們都說，不是識別
是具象的內容，這
在某種程度上說，我們可以想到基本的
無內容認知形式
或無內容水平的基本認知水平，
它通過
對一個人的環境的積極探索和
超越激進和激進主義而出現 我們的
意思是
這可能是這個想法可以
在掌握感覺運動參與方面兌現
一個知道的問題 - 如何
知道如何與
周圍環境互動，而不是知道周圍的
事物，所以這
很明顯是 Paulo 和
他的同事以及呃 kimero
在他們的書中所做的，呃激進主義和激進主義
有一定的歪曲傾向 感官
模型參與 感官模型方案
等等
，
但是最近的發展我認為已經
合併了，所以這是
對這個想法的要點的使用，
所以如果我們將
反芻或激進和激進主義的激進體現觀點
與經典燃料結合起來
我們所擁有的理性是角度
描述如下
的東西激進主義是這樣一種觀點，即
認知基於對世界的祈禱理性
理解，這種理解基於
對現實生活情況的感覺運動獲得
，他解釋了這些，呃，這種
預先的想法
嗯
，根據海德格爾的思想，
與世界的關係只能是一個植根於
p 的理性理解。 實習生在表演和
練習中的不活躍是通過身體來調節
的，所以這裡似乎隱含的
是，與表演和練習不同，
理性
實際上並不是一種非常
基本的結合水平，所以
這就是當我們
為植根於主動和實踐的基本認知水平騰出空間，
並將其與更高層次的
組合分開，它們通常
是理性的幸運經典的軌跡，
所以
總而言之，這個想法是
有爭議的認知或
通過感官出現的基本認知 運動
參與不是理性的，
所以感官的現代參與，但是
不能從理性的角度評估多產的美德
只有認知的內容
高級組合可以是理性的
定義，
例如在信仰中表達，
最近很好，這就是 我
沒有在紙上提到，但這
是我隱含的動機
作為來自心靈哲學的人，對這個主題
的理解是關於給定神話的想法，
至少當時我認為它的一個版本，嗯，我
被一位評論家正確地說服了不要
觸及這個主題
在我最初的介紹中非常複雜，
但在我看來，如果我們將
基本認識與理性的思想
和行動分開，並且我們不指向
井，那麼我的意思是
這兩個層面之間沒有交集，似乎
激進主義和激進主義和 嗯，類似的
觀點將致力於
神話不被賣方普及和
麥克道爾的節製作為
我頭腦中專橫的領域的一個問題，
所以這似乎是我認為
[音樂]
一個哲學上有趣的問題，
但它不是什麼 呃
，在論文的最前面，我
在這裡的隱含動機是解釋
我們如何通過感官現代參與將無內容或
基本的認知水平
與比率結合起來 本質如果
你不能，似乎呃有
某種給定的
東西在我們的心智圖景中沒有被完全解釋，所以這是我
想要的我仍然想嘗試
更清楚地探索這個直覺，但我
沒有 沒有
提到
這個，
但是我認為有一些東西可以
說明為什麼我今天要展示的
是我認為這是一種方式來消除
這種
對既定神話的指責，
所以我們如何才能重新構想理性我的
意思是 我認為為了避免這個
問題並避免我們有
兩個完全分開的層次的想法，
其中一個更高的層次是
經典理性的軌跡，而
在它下面還有什麼不是理性的，我
認為這個想法是拒絕
理性它 必須定義，否則
必然需要推理
不需要仍然構思，
但挑戰變成了提出一個
積極的
建議，即如果不是推理，理性是什麼
，這裡是 Susan H  urley 在一篇
論文中說，我的知識是唯一
關於這個主題的知識，我認為她當時
也很關心
給定的神話，他是
從這裡的一個長引用 phenomide 我
讀它是理性 可能
來自不同水平層
之間的抑制促進和協調的集中層次關係的複雜系統，
每一個都是動態的和環境
位置的理性，以
水平或模塊化的術語重新構想呃我不
知道她是否必須使用這個
術語但是 無論如何，這就是她
選擇表達的方式 它與環境可持續地
相關 它
不僅取決於
在輸入和輸出之間進行調解的內部程序，
例如整個有機體
或垂直邊界
中央認知模塊的內容，而是
取決於 專用世界之間的複雜關係，
涉及
監控和響應 n 特定方面
的層 自然和社會環境
以及神經網絡，並
從他們的反應中減少他們的反饋
據我所知，這是最早的
一個人從事非主動方法
的案例，顯然更
通常與 avano 的工作有關
，它也是一個激進主義者，但
在與激進主義和激進主義不同的方法中
，這是
我寫那篇論文之前最早的，據我所知
，最清晰
的理性建議是
用本土術語重新構思的，但這並不是
在她發表後獲得牽引力的東西 我的知識
實際上從那時起我並沒有看到太多
，總結一下這個想法是我們
必須改變解釋性焦點
，即理性不僅僅
被認為是一個內容，涉及
它所在的提案中的容量
或涉及增加的世界的世界
它是否從根本上體現它
取決於身體形態和行為
以及有機體如何定位和
行為 在那種環境中，這個想法將
是最低限度的死，所以這就是我所說的
徹底不活躍的
理性，嗯，
到目前為止，這是一個非常鬆散的定義，即亞洲人
在人類
與她的環境保持熟練的互動，
協調她的
認知能力的情況下，理性地行事 根據
約束
和固定站的環境條件，當然這
有時需要適應
不可預見的情況，
核心直覺是
這樣的，將這種
激進和積極理性
的想法與蘇珊赫爾利在
2003 年的一篇文章中的另一個想法進行比較是很有趣的。 她說
表演的原因，她
認為，表演的原因可能與上下文有關
，她反對 呃
Gareth Evans 的普遍性約束
，這是對實際理性島嶼的想法的辯護，
所以她仍然將理性
本質上視為相關的東西 在
這裡推理，但這種
推理是有限的 d 從實際
情況
來看，所以如果與我一開始談到的傳統觀點相比，這是一個非常進步的觀點，
但仍然比
我在這裡試圖發展的更保守，
所以我認為另一件事必須是，呃
，這是最前沿的 建議
是，理性意味著代理和
自治，因為有機體所做的某事或僅
某事可以
說是理性的權利，
因此使用這些來自
自治和激進主義陣營的想法以及
如何玩家的理論是
自治系統，例如 Roomba
不可能是理性的，因為它不是
代理它不是自己行為的作者，
它是由外部代理設計的
，以某種方式工作，所以
嚴格來說它不是一個國家，所以這
就是我要劃清界限的
地方 例如，你不能將理性歸於 Roomba 是沒有意義的
，為此
我使用了 DiPaolo 和其他人的自主性和
適應性的概念，你
有一個 還有最近的一本書，圖像
四感官模型生活和
2005 年碗裡的那篇著名論文，他
談到了適應性
，以設置他
對俄羅斯意味著什麼的非常普遍的限制，
因此自治系統被
認為是不穩定的網絡
不穩定的過程網絡，因為
組織和物理邊界是
由系統本身產生的，
系統不斷地維持它自己的
生存能力條件，這就是
所謂的意義建構，其中
系統探索
了有
利於它的自我維持的環境環境條件和
避免那些對它有害的東西，
所以這就是我理解
的最普遍的方式，即他們
對理性存在的情感約束
，它必須是一個自治系統
，這裡有趣的
是保羅的適應性概念，但
第四是
有機體通過自我生產來改善自身條件的能力
h 內部
結構變化，
因此它涉及
對內部變化的監控和調節，
以便選擇最佳
可行的行動方案。
不一定致力於
推理和內容，
因此代理是通過
行使
情境能力來實現的
或表明其合理
性，有機體越理性，
它就越適合處理其
環境，我們已經預見到了
情況，
並且在這樣做的過程中，有機體增強了
自身與環境之間的持續交流，
這對其生存和 這
是非常
自然的理性思維方式
主要是
為了生存而增強變化的能力
這是
這裡的總體想法，
所以正如我之前所說的，我想要推理
我不想用推理來必然地提交理性
，這
就是根本不活躍的理性的
全部意義，但我 不想將
推理排除為以前的理性
組合，所以我要說的是，
它不是由推理定義的，但
不是，它不排除
推理，我認為推理將被認為是
一種特殊或特定的理性
代理模式 這是我們
人類所獨有的知識，
但它不是理性的定義特徵，
所以為此我呃，為了解釋
這個想法，我記得胡圖和土星
是如何在 utani 最近的書中的論文之間
解釋的
高度認可的出現 這個想法是，
能夠參與
認知內容最終取決於
社會文化嵌入
，內容完全認知
來自社會 當
一個人參與社會
文化實踐時，
他們接受了更古老的認知
能力來處理符號，並且通過
這樣做，他們
在一個漫長的文化適應過程中，
當然
他們變得能夠參與呃
符號協調，這不是
內部的 特定的表徵，因為
它是公開的，它不是
傳統意義上的心理表徵，
但它具有符號認知的特徵，
沒有對
內部表徵或心理
表徵的承諾，
因此在最一般
意義上的理性行動是這樣一種觀念，即一個人的熟練
行為 有機體在呃
是一個有機體
在其環境中的熟練行為，它
取決於具體能力的協調，
而如果一切順利，推理
當然被理解
為理性的內容，因為我的特定
理性模式推理是一個熟練的
行為 社會
文化中的有機體
環境當然是我們環境的一個更具體的方面
，它
取決於這種文化基礎或內容的協調，這些
內容涉及
在人類系統發育尺度上較新的
能力，這是最大的
想法，這是 我認為
是積極的部分，這裡
是我想談的
第一個反對意見是，這是一個非常自由的
觀點，非常，
嗯，很好，它包含了太多的
人會說，因為如果理性行動
歸結為協調 對於
認知能力，理性
是漸進的，因為一個有機體
可能或多或少地精通其
環境相互作用
，而拒絕是根據
根本不活躍的理性進行的，許多
有機體在利基中實現並維持一種
適應性行為，並
取得不同程度的成功
嗯，有人可以為自由黨唱理性
和積極的激進和積極的
理性，這是
我親自聽到的一個反對意見
，我一直很努力，因為我認為
這是一種很好的表達方式，
即使釘子在
這個觀點上是理性的，我必須
說我願意購買 錢包
嗯，是的，它比
傳統觀點更自由，當然它是
有意的，但我不認為
這本身就是我認為的問題，
這裡的積極部分是它
保留了人類的程度差異
比其他動物更理性，
僅僅是因為我們能夠
在各種各樣的動態環境中執行各種各樣的動作，
這遠遠超出
了我們所知道的任何其他動物，
所以回到這個釘子的例子，
這個釘子可以 執行一些複雜的
動作可以從一個點移動到
另一個點它可以尋找食物和
住所等等，但是如果
你用南方包圍這個釘子，它們的能力有限
，例如它注定要死
另一方面，反駁和人類
他們更具適應性，
能夠動態處理許多
不可預見的情況，所以嗯
，我對這個反對意見的回應是，
是的，
嗯，它非常自由，但這
不是問題，如果
那樣的話 如果它
在動物如何處理它們的環境之間存在程度差異的空間，
那麼這是另一個對象
反對，我認為它可能是
你最感興趣的一個，那麼
你知道的是 12 預測處理
似乎一直暗示著推論和內容
，
但首先我必須警告你
和觀眾，
在我寫這篇文章的時候，這篇
論文對這種
將行動主義和
預測編碼或預測
處理相結合的可能性更加樂觀，呃 我認為這裡有一些
重要的觀點，但是
Olu 和 Evan Thompson 以及 Randy beer 最近的這篇論文
，他們呃他們
提供了對呃 th 的批判性評估
嘗試主要結合
自由能原理和
不活躍和
自傳理論，所以我現在
大多被這些論點說服，但我
認為這裡有一些有趣
的比較點，
儘管如此，我們的預測
代碼中的預測過程和呃 在我寫作的時候
，直到今天仍然
在認知科學中
風靡一時
在這些觀眾中，您知道
競爭被理解為
在雙向狹窄層次結構中發生的錯誤最小化過程，
因此
您可以
為較低層的活動生成內部模型，該模型
可以預測險惡刺激的遠端原因，
這是一個 自上而下的
過程和最小化
預測和
當前刺激信號之間的差異，由
um 佔用先驗
是過程的底部，
所以這里當然是主動推理
，例如，
在非正式的你知道克拉克的正式術語中
，有機體移動其傳感器
的方式相當於我們這一代人積極尋求的方式，
從而產生它們相當的感官後果 他們的
大腦期望
這是理解積極
影響非常正式的術語的一種方式，但我
認為它可以完成
工作，如果看起來我的存在有問題，大腦會推斷
接收到的刺激的預期來源
談論
所以他投票閱讀預測
處理，它使用
產品偏差和推理
權，例如，
感知
主義者的過程與
增殖和上下文自上而下
效應的理性更廣泛的偏見過程是分開的，我覺得每個中間
水平的 處理這件事引起了我的
注意，克拉克一直
在談論理性，
但這是一個 n 推理類型的
理性
和普遍的影響者推理
似乎暗示了無所不在的內容
，然後預測處理
似乎與根本不活躍的
理性不相容，但是當時
有，我認為我們仍然可以在
其中爭論一些沒有
非 - 痔瘡和
預測處理
的閱讀，例如，第一步
將是使用通貨緊縮的預測意義，
即在 2013 年的一篇短文中理解客串，
但第四步，其中
兩個或多個變量
的值 covari 或值是可靠的，所以
值 1 允許觀察者推斷
另一個的值，這裡的
推斷發生在
觀察的水平上，而不是在一個遠
變量推斷另一個的值，
所以我
認為內容在眼中
旁觀者 解釋
我們選擇的審查員如何
近似於此處理解的內部預測的人
通貨膨脹的感覺可以
用推論和偏見的術語來描述它，
所以這就是我如何看待
布魯諾論文關於 4 000 的想法
，如果我沒記錯的話，它的
標題就像大腦
不是科學家，論點在
我們正在預測的這個大方向，
科學家們如何將大腦活動解釋
為大腦本身的一個特徵，就好像它
在預測和推斷這種更
強大或更重要的感覺，
所以我在這裡想說的是
主動推理，然後我使用雙重 並且
說雙重忘記了英語的名稱
對不起，
這不是根據根本不活躍的推理的字面意義，
呃理性是沒有武裝
的共同導向行為的效率，
代理必須以某些方式行動，
以便他的 他或她的狀態
更有效地實現結果，成本更低，
這並不
意味著生成模型
本身顯示和執行
預測推理的主張更具爭議性 es 這是對預測處理的一種非常
通縮的解讀
，以提供
這種具有激進和積極
理性的組合
，這是 2018 年的一篇論文中的
開場白
，它並不認為
有機體具有
其生態位的內部表徵模型，
因為它
如果你願意的話，這些是認知工作的模型嗎？相反，
有機體是一個模型，它是因果關係
和統計規律反映在
某些環境中，反映了一些
表型，它是一個模型
，
這與最近
我和我的同事 notifica 的事情有關 一直在
談論有機體如何
根據
激進主義創造一個世界的想法，這是一種想法，即有機體
和環境在
歷史上被稱為確定的，因此
在流動遺傳尺度上，這可以
通過利基
構造的想法來解釋 一個
有機體在其環境中是活躍的，它會
促進變化，如果它們
足夠穩定 它們可以被其
後代繼承，這些變化提供了新的
進化壓力壓力
，這些壓力引導了它的進化路徑
理性行動意味著
通過某種方式預測
和最小化
來實現與環境
的熟練接觸
無意義預測及其最小化
涉及世界參與方式中輸入的選擇和
交互性的協調，
這
正是激進和積極人格的主要主張，
所以我認為在
某種程度上，預測處理不是
呃敵人，而是
而不是這個想法的謊言而不是呃
到達而是c 我們還有其他
的兼容性問題，我
在這裡沒有涉及到，但這就是
我今天想到的所有內容，
謝謝，
很棒，非常感謝，很好，
很酷，
對那些正在觀看現場直播的人來說很有趣，請
隨意 寫下任何問題我會
收集我的筆記，讓我們開始
討論
好吧，
首先再次感謝你的
談話
，關於你如何
在
你目前的職位上提出這些問題以及你
在這個領域的興趣如何發展的一些背景，因為
有 這麼多有趣的想法，我
只是想更多地了解你
是如何得出這個框架的，並加強你的
觀點，
好的，謝謝，這是一個很好的
問題，因為你並不經常
可以探索這個背景，
這很重要，所以我當時是
我想我當時正在寫我的博士論文，
那可能是 2007 年之類的，嗯，我
在爭論
理性必須是
最終與世界有關的東西 有一種
思考的傾向，即使
我告訴你，正如我向你展示的那樣，在
與某些人的具體化時期中，
它本質上需要是世界，
涉及諸如行動和實踐
等等
，當然還有感知，但理性
仍然存在 類似於可自然化的
概念之類的東西，
它
不能以某種方式按比例縮小，
例如可以
通過某種動態參與來解釋的感知
等等，
所以當時我想得很好
也許這是
一個膝蓋問題，因為
在其他
其他情況下，它被認為是暗示，
如果它沒有
以某種方式表達出來以提供
與專業組合的某種契合，
那麼感知是給定的
，這是給定維度的神話
一開始，我想
，也許這
有點像是
給定的在積極認知上工作的神話，
但這不是我認為的
不是致命的，因為我們不能原則上
爭論，而
不是解釋步驟感知和
其他涉及概念等的基本組合形式，
也許我們
可以
從另一個方向爭論，嘗試
在更非自然化的
水平上縮小
理性
所以這就是動機，
這是一個漫長的審查過程，我
相信我的第一個
論文的第一個版本，觀眾非常我
認為他們完全正確我
畢竟支持了這個建議，但
他非常呃
他們 非常堅定地參與
其中，我認為這是更好的，
因為它是另一種文學，它
是另一種，呃，很多參考文獻
通常不會與
激進主義和身體識別進行對話，而且
很難僅僅把
以同樣的方式推進我的論點，
所以這是我劃掉的東西
，我沒有對
那個系統考慮太多，但我認為這是我
想要的東西 回過頭來，也許，
甚至可能有人
在過去幾年中這樣
做過 所以我認為
我們可以我們應該的東西我的意思是呃能夠
探索但是沒有什麼
東西在論文的最前沿
但是我有這個想法來談論
閃爍的每一個意義上的理性
同時 當我讀到很多
關於呃
從哲學的角度打電話給他
的時候，我當然不像我說的那樣
非常精通這種方法的技術細節
和形式，
但我對
那裡的哲學後果很感興趣，我
想得很好 也許這裡有一些東西可以
比較，因為正如克拉克的
引文所示，
你可以一直談論
理性，嗯，這是我想要發展的東西，
但不是從認知主義的觀點來看，
但不是從根本上體現的電影，所以
這就是背景
真棒謝謝你能不能
描述一下
什麼是給定的神話這個神話出現的背景是什麼
以及在
提出給定的神話之後我們該去哪裡
因為我認為它是一個概念 你
編織了，所以它是什麼，
好吧，所以在給予它的中間有幾個可能的給予，這
取決於你對我的哲學的風格，
但最經典的是在先前
的心靈領域中，將
感知的內容給予
以一種我們有某些輸入的方式理性地祈禱，這些
輸入是大腦剛剛接收到的
，大腦會解釋它，所以
賣家不同的賣家以
呃描述他的呃這個問題而聞名，這個
問題不僅增加
了心靈的燃料，而且還 對於理性主義者，
但另一方面，理性
通常被視為
給定的理性直覺，也就是說，存在
某種程度的認知，
呃，它說不清楚。  s 給定的，或者正如有些
人所說的被培養給定的，
但在某種程度上，存在這種
認知水平，並且大腦必須
對其進行解釋，但如果以這種方式給予
它，它就沒有接觸
點，任何東西之間都沒有交叉點
無論頭腦做什麼，以及這種基本
的統治水平，所以我的想法是
避免被指控致力於
給定的神話，但這
在本土主義文學中並不是明確的，
但
它似乎是
我的意思是在這種比較中可能會發展，
但這不是不是從
那裡不清楚而是
解決它們的一種方法讓
Givens說感知內容
在本質上已經是概念性的，
例如Joe McDowell如何
記住更多的是你知道一種
看法呃笑話是帶有
字幕的你並
像你一樣解釋世界但是呃
我認為一種或另一種方式
是揭開你的神秘面紗你知道理性 並且
組合的上層嘗試並
嘗試在不提交它們的情況下將它們考慮在較少的
內容中進行分析
，所以嚴格
來說，它具有與基本組合水平分離的內容水平，這是
我認為這樣做的一種方式
，並且 理性似乎是
做到這一點的一個關鍵概念，因為
它通常被假定為
完全是人類的東西，並且
與推理有關，如果是
這樣，那麼理性就不能指導行動
，當然，如果行動
本質上是無內容的 因此，如果理性
是一種本質上是滿足的感覺，而反應本質上是無內容的，
那麼你可以沒有
這個
呃，這兩個領域之間的這個呃交叉
，這
是我想避免的，但正如我
告訴你的那樣，它變得如此難以
以
足夠清晰和籠統的方式表達這種觀點是
，根據我們的審稿人的建議，我把它
刪掉了，
我仍然在想我 t 但是沒有什麼我
沒有發展出一條正確
的論據線，
比我能做的更清楚地處理它，因為我只是
用非常籠統的術語做的
很酷，你與理性相關的一些詞
是適應性
和熟練度，所以你看到了什麼
作為一種生物功能的理性和適合度的關係
是的 是的 好吧
我認為這是一種內在的
關係 真的
我們
談論理性
是呃某些物種的特徵還是不是
個體的特徵我認為健身是這裡的關鍵概念之一，
將
其
視為這種呃理性行為的結果，
所以雖然我沒有說我沒有
把它放在論文中的那些問題上 我
認為可以這樣想
o
如果
它還沒有本能，那麼每個
生物體都接受這個結果 處理
呃敵人不斷變化的環境，
但是很好，這是擁有
非常
自由的理性進步概念的代價，
這是
它的結果我相信
所以你說過健身
是理性的結果行為是否
有其他後果或 我們如何
從外部認識到理性，
而不是僅僅說好
蟻群正在蓬勃發展，以至於
它是理性的，它是適應
展覽機構的，所有這
一切都是這樣一個通貨緊縮的
理性概念，所有現存的
人類和事物 否則僅
由它描述，或者是否有一些
結果可以用來解開
例如理性或非
理性行為與僅
由 su 反映的後果 生存和
健身
很好，我必須非常
仔細地考慮這個問題，因為我
不想輕視這個概念，
因為一切都是事實的 IPS
認為，呃，在特定情況下，一個人
可以呃確定我
與個人平等的國家，
嗯，在那個利基市場中自我維持，所以
在個人層面，特別是
好的，這是一個決定性的某些
行為，可能分類
者在某種程度上是非理性的，他們 呃
對生存有害，但是
呃在物種層面上，
以這種方式爭論更困難，因為
要確定這種行為或
後果，但我認為
為了不輕視理性的想法，
並說好一切
生活是一個因素，你必須
確定這種不利於生存的特定行為
，
所以在蟻群的情況下，我
可能不知道
歡迎入侵者將是一種
不利於
生存的行為，因此
我不知道我不知道這是不是，
這是一種不可能的思考方式，
我必須更清楚地思考，
但
我的 仔細
哦，非常有趣，您
在演示文稿中引入了這個答案，
就像 Eco Evo
Devo 所做的那樣，從更生物學的
角度來看待生態位
構造如何彌合
較慢的系統發育過程和更
快速的發育過程之間的差距，
嗯，所以 這種
嵌入式和多尺度考慮
如何與內容
概念相關，例如內容將
在一個主體中本地化，還是內容
分佈在實體之間，或者
理性分佈在實體之間
，我們如何識別
理性的軌跡？ 還從您提供的報價中
調用了 um 水平和模塊化
概念，
所以我們如何識別顯著性
時空尺度和
感興趣的系統
哦，我不知道我不知道我是否可以
完全回答這個問題，但在我看來，
如果我們談論的
是內容，例如內容作為
準確性 象徵性
思想的條件 我認為幸運的是，我們不得不
說它不是本地化的，
它是公開共享的，
所以你可以說，
嗯
，這樣做的一個結果是，
可以考慮不同
的推理模式，這些模式已經
成為信息
站點 在不同的時間等等，你可以
看到他們為內容信息制定了不同
級別的不同呃規則
，我認為這是
合理的說內容
是本地化的，
呃你怎麼能說它分享
你知道的細節的數量
只是出於理性，我認為
如果它符合這些，則可以[音樂]識別特定
行為 有機體與其環境之間的相互作用
它的利基所以
我們可能可以在這裡給出不同的答案
作為理性和內容我
願意說
組織的內容
不是發生在頭腦
中的東西以某種方式
分享 其他人的數量，這是
我的哲學
至少從 60 年代以來就一直存在的東西，
我的哲學家一直在爭論
內容是外部個體化的想法
，嗯，我認為這是它
的視頻之一 例如 Hillary Putnam
和 Tyler Burge 等人認為
心理內容在社區層面或社會層面是個體化的，
但另一方面，他們認為
理性原則上可以
在特定行為中個體化，
但這取決於個人的
目標和 它所居住的利基
等等
，當然這裡有實際變量
，對於識別行為也可能很重要
無論是理性還是
不好，
謝謝，
嗯，一個真正
困擾我的短語就像知道如何不知道這
也許是你工作中的一個基點，
並且專注於那個動作，所以我只是
想
听聽你在編織時是如何行動和練習的
他們今天在這裡，這些術語是如何
處理
的，今天的事情與
行動、實踐和
技術的處理有何不同
我
認為，
嗯
，嗯，這是
一種非常現代哲學的趨勢，
但它在認知科學的第一波浪潮中非常有影響力，
將感知視為
對環境進行分類
並提供離散的能力。
環境方面的描述，例如
，感知
到我知道杯子在我的左邊
是一個知道
有搜索這些屬性的東西的問題
我的左邊，這是一種呃知道
那種
對世界的命題態度所以
呃我認為
激進主義和
生態心理學也很有趣
，以至於他們從一開始就回憶起美國
的實用主義 本
世紀將
感知視為不是對世界上
這些偉大的屬性進行分類的問題，
而是將其視為揭示行為的
可能性
，如果我們用諸如知識
之類的流行術語來解釋這一點，
我們將不會”
不是說知道
曲線在我的左邊，而是知道如何
拿起杯子，
如果我想喝一杯
咖啡，或者如果我想把它用作
鎮紙它將具有不同的
無聲屬性，儘管我認為這是非常重要的
，
但
我認為激進主義和生態
心理學以及其他具體的認知觀點
在 shif 中已基本成功 把這個討論討論到這
一點我認為在更
傳統的認知科學中你仍然
有這樣的想法，即
通過
描述環境的方式來感知有機體有機體，
這是我認為
更傳統的
預測處理解讀使呃清楚
就像你在
推斷刺激的來源而不是
在呃和不是這不是我的意思是
這更容易接受
大腦或認知
系統
知道世界是
某某環境是某某，而不是
說議程系統知道如何
與世界互動，我
相信活動家和生態
心理學家試圖提出的觀點是
，並致力於預測
編碼和自由能原理
等是為了表明這些概念這些
框架可能是一個最小的想法，
即 kubernetes 系統知道如何
參與它知道如何參與 ge in
environment in a way it doesn't need to
be read inboard summary
that the Kindle system is infering
that the world is so所以我認為這是
一種解釋方式，但從哲學上講，
如果你在開頭有一個大
在過去的幾
十年裡，一場關於
是否沒有云可以簡化為
知道這一點的巨大討論，然後你再次擁有
這個和其他的背景
作為一個獨立的概念，你知道
那個，以及你是否可以
將一個簡化為另一個等等 所以
我認為它並不止於此，你不能
呃，即使我可以聲稱
其他人知道
他們
如何仍然是技術是否可以被視為的背景問題
，
無論如何這都是 我
最近也在研究
，有很多話要說，這
是一個非常有趣的想法，尤其是在
語言交流方面，它
有點像手指和月亮，
談論月亮，但手指
只是 它在哪裡，我們不是在
談論指針，而是在
談論參考
，因此使用
文化語言
或書面學術話語中的社會認知交流形式
來窺視或重新想像它，
甚至看到看起來的東西 就像
知道這一點的頂峰一樣
，仍然把它看作知道
我猜的問題是
我們如何閱讀論文
是的，當然是的
一個非常大的問題，因為如果
我們嘗試將
您提到的這些負面能力視為技術問題
，似乎我們仍然會錯過
一些關於溝通的東西，
另一方面，我認為這是我的
直覺，但我認為 我們
原則上可以談論
如何
理解你剛才所說的並
試圖回應它是一個
知道如何在語言上表現的問題，
但我認為即使是這種對待高水平認知主義者的運動
也讓我 不是技術問題，它
仍然遺漏了一些東西
例如，以
非常充分的方式進行交流，而不是說它
不涉及現在，但這不僅
是我認為至少需要的不僅僅是
實踐知識，
而且這裡的關鍵可能是認為
實踐知識只是基本的和
其他類型的必要知識 其他
類型的知識，他們
需要參與這種交流
，也許也許這是一層
至少我目前的立場是，
沒有辦法為我們
與世界和
其他人的接觸提供基礎，但在某個時刻，我們
必須能夠發展其他類型的
理解來解釋一個非常
解釋複雜的呃
我們在日常生活中進行的交流，
例如閱讀你所說的論文，
我同意我認為
框架知道作為基礎，然後
恢復知道如何是一個挑戰
，從基礎認知過程開始也是一個挑戰，
因為
沒有房子和 重新組裝這些
專有技術，再次知道
這不一定是一個簡單的
挑戰，而是我們寧願面對
從更
閾限的生態認知方法組裝像徵性命題陳述性語言等認知過程的挑戰，
還是嘗試從圖靈中恢復生態
從某種意義上說是機器，所以
看起來
你是在支持建立
在生態合理的基礎認知
過程中的基礎，然後努力
組裝摩天大樓
是的，是的，完全是的，我認為
這兩種方法都很好
正如你所說的那樣，要提供
這種呃那種
左下角或自上而下的解釋，但我 我
當然更喜歡網絡
方法，我認為這也是另一個
原因，它似乎從出發點來看
似乎是
對我們如何與世界互動的生物學描述，
而
相反的方式似乎要
困難得多 解釋呃我們是如何
提出這個呃生物學
問題的 至少我認為
這是
一種自下而上的方法
在某種程度上更具有綜合性，從某種意義上說，
它似乎更有可能
對我們有利
，而且你只是把
它框起來的方式讓我覺得如果你是 要
從頭開始對計算機進行編程，
它可以是抽象計算機或虛擬
計算機，因此它甚至不需要
具有特定實施例
，在這種情況下，人們可能會
關心組裝
知道斷言並組裝
這些聲明 ative
語句和邏輯處理成
更具動態性或
與環境交互的東西，但是
，像全棧工程這樣的過程，
以邏輯和矽為基礎，
與我們到達這裡的方式完全不同
，所以它可能會，但它是
互補的，
嗯 你給了一點可見性，
嗯，我猜是在
同行評審之前和之後，所以我只是
好奇在過去的幾個月或幾年裡
，論文期間和之後發生了什麼變化，
或者
不管你在這方面是如何發展的
，然後是什麼 您認為
接下來的步驟是否相關，無論它們是為您準備的還是
只是一般性的，我們是否正在
尋找大腦測量 我們是否正在
尋找森林中的攝像機 我們是否
正在尋找一個概念性的 Advance
將要向前推進的事情 你的
發展
這是一個很好的問題我想
嗯
我對
我使用外國水平的方式並不完全滿意我不
知道這是否會
進行你 t in uh 老實說，我不知道
您是否可以原則上以
其他經驗術語進行，但是，
我並不是說，嗯，
一個是我今天會寫得有點
不同，並不是
說我不同意
最初是論文，但我想我
有一些觀點我
想重新構建，但他們沒有
授權，呃，我認為他有一篇新
論文，
但也許在未來，但這
是神話等問題
給出的問題 仍然是哲學
問題
和概念問題，他們仍然困擾著
我，但我還
沒有找到機會
更仔細地發展這些想法以及
我在那裡提出的一般觀點我想我認為
它仍然存在，
但是
我想要我我 我仍然在等待
這個機會進一步闡述它，
看看我能走多遠，但我還不知道
我必須承認我不知道
這個想法的未來發展是什麼，
但我一直在努力 關於幾個
孤立的
問題
在過去幾年裡，我
一直在研究
這種方法 是我喜歡如何進行
研究以找到有趣的
呃問題，看看我該如何
處理它們，但不一定會發現
自己
呃與
一種推理方式聯繫在一起，所以這
就是我工作時發生的事情
理性，如果我認為這
是一個非常酷的主題，嗯，我仍然
認為它是，但我還沒有
時間回來重新定義我想要的
，但是，也許在
不久的將來的某個時候，我不知道，但更多
我最近一直在
做的事情不涉及細胞
理性，但我認為有些產品
可能是錯誤的，即
虛擬現實產品，
以及視覺現實
與 com 相比如何
因為很明顯
，毅力和視覺環境中缺少一些東西，
嗯，當然，如果我有人，
例如，如果我在一個視覺
環境中，我處於一種威脅之下，
我可能會感到類似於
恐懼的東西，但是 我並沒有真正擔心我的
生命，
並想像虛擬現實中的人
因此
逃離威脅是合理的虛擬威脅
等等等等這就是這就是這
就是我正在工作 嗯，也許它為激進和積極理性的想法
提供了一個回歸點
，事實上
，正如我在過去幾天如此忙碌之前告訴你的那樣，這篇論文剛剛被接受，
因為我們正在糾正
我的證明 同事和我從來沒有比喻過
，我和我的
時間也很緊
，在過去幾週提交論文的更正版本，然後我
得到了證明，
哦，
好吧，也許未來我
可以回到國際空間站 出於理性
我願意，但我不知道我
是否不知道我真的無法預見它的
發展，但總的來說我
仍然同意我最初的想法，但
我會稍微改變一下 有點
所以 VR 點我敢肯定那裡還有
很多話要說，但它讓我
想起了虛擬現實這個標題，它是一種
虛擬化，所以就像
認知行動計劃
允許我們接受
我們的身體不接受的政策一樣
不要只評估它們並選擇
反對它們，但我們可以繼續
幻想，在心理上有一個異想天開的反事實政策
選擇過程
，
但我們的形態有點像
我們的生命線，如果你真的
從窗台上掉下來，那就是 會受傷
，然後在虛擬現實中，
你體現
了知覺體驗實際上
是生存危急情況的虛擬化，
所以你
可能會認為自己在窗台上，
但你在平坦的地板上
，然後在那種情況下
如果你是
電子遊戲之外的認知觀察者，你可能會說
，我只是停下來看看
會發生
什麼是合理的 在遊戲中，
嗯，所以它有點模糊
[音樂]之間
的界限，它模糊了身體的關鍵性
，嗯，
我相信你已經考慮過
更多了，所以這如何在我們的
虛擬現實中發揮作用
我們思考、使用
和設計這些系統的方式，
這
就是促使我們寫
論文的問題，嗯，NADA 給了他們，我
是在技術文獻中，你
看到很多研究人員
與 呃把呃視覺感知
當作一種幻覺，但我們對此
有點困擾，因為
另一方面它只適用於虛擬現實，因為
我們體現了他們
為我們工作的設備你有控制器你
有頭 設置
，呃，說
用戶處於一種幻覺之下似乎很奇怪
，另一方面，這似乎
不是真正的認知，因為正如你
所說，
與那些呃認知沒有生物學相關性
可以這麼說，例如，如果我
在 VR 中看到一個蘋果，它不提供
營養，但它在遊戲中是有道理的，
但不同的是，
我在實際環境中收到一個蘋果，
它提供
營養 這是我可以吃的東西，
但不能在 VR 中我可以假裝，所以我們
創造了這個 uh 暗示
它的平面的概念
uh 就好像我們
面對的是一個真正的動物，但它也涉及
這種玩的意願這個想法
，我們不是
被誤導是因為
我們在遊戲中使用了我們知道的設備，
我認為這是現在的熱門話題，
因為有隱喻，我
對人們非常樂觀的任何事情持懷疑態度，
但
對元音的可能性持懷疑態度 rse
和一些作者真的認為我們
可以在這個
嚴格意義上進行模擬，但我的意思是
當前技術向我們展示的最好的技術
是它非常有限，你可以
假裝在某個環境
中等等，我認為 可能會提供
一種新的思維方式來
思考這種
視覺環境中的理性，也許
俄羅斯人會做一些
環境所說的事情來跳下窗台，看看
會發生什麼，另一方面
，這樣做的行為方面有時
人們會真正感覺到 恐懼和人們
因對虛擬現實的恐懼而面對街頭
，
嗯，這是很多，那裡有很多
有趣的問題，
也許我的意思是為了未來的研究，我們可以
回到它，這讓我想到
了蘋果在現實生活中的表現 可能
是你的卡路里，也可能
是蒼蠅的卡路里 它可以被扔掉
你可以把它當作錘子 你可以
把它畫得恰到好處 所以
生態和生成 正如
我們所說的那樣，一種主動推理的
過程總是超越
為給定對象編程的任何可供性，然後
嗯，當前關於 VR 的討論主要
集中在耳機上，
只是說完全是軼事而
不是我的專業領域，
嗯，這似乎是 有點有趣
好像手機
討論只集中在
一定大小的矩形上 是
什麼讓這不是虛擬現實
就像透過窗戶
看到另一個人可以說話 所以
它不依附在我的頭上 它不
具有某些技術所具有的一些運動
跟踪能力，
但它
是 Perry 個人空間中的一個小眾修改
，我們可以將
信號和可供性相互推送，
因此擁有一個 VR 框架，或者實際上只是一個
理性和感知
認知動作的框架循環
不僅限於一種特定的
實現或硬件類型，並且可以
運行從
一個領域的總離線人員
到 s 一些
在黑客帝國中
非常重要的人似乎非常相關，否則新
技術即使是很小的變體和
軟件更新也會繼續
無限驚喜和困惑
是的，我認為這是一個很難
定義界限
我的意思是我們在這裡呃
交換 我認為它可能會增加，但被
歸類為虛擬現實的一種形式，
當然我看到你毀了你的 C
思維，
但我的意思是大多數我認為他們
現在可以解決問題，他們發現它是一個文檔，
說必須有一個耳機
有時是控制器，但
除此之外聽起來是虛擬現實，但是
是的，很難定義任何東西，嗯
，不是，它不是垃圾，
直截了當，這是其中的一件事，
因為在商業上，
當然虛擬現實意味著耳機
和其他用具，但是但是 在那個時候，一部
電話只是在打電話或
打電報，它本來會
在那個界面上，帶有那種感官
模式和那些可供
性 虛擬
化 是的，我們今天可以訪問的只是
不同的
章節 體現技術設備
是什麼讓我們從一
開始就使用分析技術，
以及我們可以如此
熟練地將它體現為一個設備，即使它被
編程為，例如，在
虛擬現實中，擁有一些
你控制我們的生物更富有 新
形態 例如另一種形態，
即使是這樣，它也只能
如此熟練地發生，因為我們
能夠體現該設備一些
實驗表明，您可以
將手腕的扭轉映射到
第三隻手臂，
嗯，個體現實來自於
從你的胸部，人們可以
學會控制第三隻手臂，
它不會映射到我們的實際形態中，
但可以通過 Twist o 來實現 f
手腕，所以
這是我們將在
我們的論文中討論的問題，你可以
你只能這樣做，因為你體現
了設備，你可以看到這是一種錯覺，
這實際上
是我作為人類的一部分是
刺繡技術設備，所以
我 會這樣我的意思是我知道它
模糊了虛擬
和非虛擬芽之間的區別我認為這
是處理這種
酷的一種方式你還有什麼想
談論的問或者只是一種前奏
啊我會的 非常感謝您有
機會討論這篇論文，這
對我來說非常好，我真的很喜歡它
，這是一個非常好的和
舒適的環境來討論這些
問題，並再次感謝你，
謝謝，是的，很棒的討論和
重要的話題 我們很樂意
隨時再次與您交談
好的 謝謝 再見 謝謝